[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんはこんな経験ありませんか
それでは一次面接を
始めますまず簡単に自己紹介をお願いし
ますはい
青山学院大学から参りました
武田荘はと申します
本日はよろしくお願いいたします
よろしくお願いいたしますでは始めに
あなたの強みを教えてください
はいあー私の
強みは
私の強みが
面接ではだいたい聞かれるんだよな
とりあえず面接最中だしなんか答えなきゃ
[音楽]
あとはこんな場面も
乾杯
乾杯ねぇもう大学4年生だよ私たちねぇ
ほんとさ
美容だよねね
空はさ将来何になりたいとか
具体的な夢決まってる
今はまだ
探してる感じかな
皆さんいかがでしたでしょうかちょっと
さっきの鳥人間の後でかなりプレッシャー
を感じているんですが
やっぱりミスコン出場者と聞いてちょっと
キラキラしたイメージをお持ちの方も
多いかもしれませんが今日は皆さんと同じ
悩みを持つ一人の大学生として
話しさせていただきます
一つのことに熱中する人とか
夢をがむしゃらに追いかける人ってかっこ
いいですよねそう私の友人にも
ダンサーを目指す人がいたり音楽活動し
てる人がいますそんな人たちの姿を見て
羨ましいなぁなんて思う時があるんです
でもここにいる皆さんの多くも私のような
悩みを感じたことがあるのではない
でしょうかそこでこれに
名前をつけてみましたそれが
情熱大陸コンプレックスです
少年漫画の主人公みたいに生きていきたい
と
憧れを抱いたことがある人はどれぐらい
いらっしゃいますか
なんかちょっとあまり
皆さんちょっと手上げてください
結構いますねではそんな主人公みたいに
情熱的に来てるよっていう方どれくらい
いらっしゃいますかちょっと
多くのスピーカーの人が
手上げてくれてますねそうですよね
やっぱり憧れることはあっても
自分が実際そのように生きるのって
結構難しいと思います
身近な話になるんですが私には2歳年の
離れた弟がいます私の弟はとにかくゲーム
が大好きで
オンライン上でコミュニティを作って
毎日ボイスチャットだったりだとか
ライブ配信を楽しんでいます
こんな私からしたら
なんでなんでそんな熱中できるのっていう
感じなんですそしてまたはこうなります
なので私は弟に聞いてみましたね
なんでそんな熱中できるのってそしたら音
だこんな一言お返してきました
え
好きだから
の一言いやいや
何か一つのことでも続けられない私にとっ
てはちょっと理解できませんでした
なので私は後悔しました
へーってでも心の中では
羨ましいって思いましたね
こんな自分の身の回りの環境が何かに
打ち込んでいたいと自分の価値観を作った
のかなと思います
実際
スポーツ選手はアーティスト
暴れるブランドの若き女性プロデューサー
を見てもその道に特化してるからこそ
キラキラして見えるしなんか特有の
覇気を感じたりしますよね
でもそんな眩しい方々の姿が
ポジティブに作業する反面
自分がそうはなりきれないという
劣等感を感じることにもつながりました
でもやっぱり私はそんなコンプレックス
取っ払いたいと思いましたなので大学3年
生の時に
ミスさん青山コンテストに出場しました
ここで皆さんに質問です
ミスは俺もコンテストについて
知ってるという方どれくらいいらっしゃい
ますか
あちょっともうちょっとしててもいいかな
と思ったんですけどちょっとちょっと
寂しいですねではミスコンに対してどんな
イメージをお持ちですか
さっき言ってたようにキラキラしてるとか
ギラギラしているとかあお嬢様が多いん
じゃないかとか
おしとやかとかそんなイメージお持ちじゃ
ないでしょうか
私も最初はそんなイメージを持っていまし
たですが活動が始まったらそのイメージは
一変
想像していた以上にハードで
インスタグラムのフォロワー数を比べて
自分が比べたくなくても比べられて
苦しんだ時期もありました
でもここで私に天気が訪れました
そんな楽しくも
苦しくもあった時期を経験する中で私に
とっては人との出会いそして関係が
何よりも
意味のあるものだということに気づいたん
です
ミスコン活動中一緒に舞台に上がってくれ
た友人がいたり
メッセージを送れるファンの方がいたり
またどんな不機嫌な状態でいても
暖かく蹴れてくれる
家族がいたりしてそういったことに気づい
た時に私は
周りの人や
関係環境への
感謝の気持ちを忘れてはいけないという
思いが芽生えました
現にハーバード大学で
約700人のアメリカ人を対象に
75年間
調査され続けた
研究においても人間の幸福度というのは
富を持っているかや
有名であるかどうかというのは関係なく
人間関係によって決まると言われているん
です
実はミスコン期間中
Instagramのサブアカウントで
弱音を吐いたことがありました
その時に何人もの友人が
温かいメッセージで励ましてくれたんです
それは自分を
自分のありのままを受け入れてくれるよう
なそんな内容でした
もちろん自分の弱音を吐くことって
恥ずかしいですよねでも一歩前に踏み出せ
ば
勇気を振り絞って助けてと言えば
手を差し伸べてくれる人がいます
そしてこんな情熱大陸コンプレックスを
持った私でしたが
徐々に考え方が変わっていきました
今まで何か一つの大きなことだけに意味を
見出していた私がそれは自分にとって
負担になりすぎていたということに気づい
たんです
これは私の人生における大きな気づきでし
た
そして
新たな視点を意識するようになり
息苦しさだけではない
充実感を得られるようになりましたその時
に私は
自分と向き合う時間を作りましたすると私
の
頭の中がこんな風になっていることに
気づいたんですそれがこちらです
まず左側から説明いたします
これは
以前の私の頭の中です
自分がこの位置にいるとしたら
自分が見ているものは
自分よりも上にあるもので
意識がこのように一方向に向いているのが
お分かりいただけると思いますこの時の私
は
未来にフォーカスする
夢を追いかけることこそが人生そんな価値
観を持っていました
そしてこれが今の私の
頭の中です
真ん中に自分がいて
周りの
周りに自分の好きを構成する
要素がこのように点在しているんです
先ほどは自分から夢に向かって一方向に
意識が向いている状態でしたが今はという
とこのように
様々な方向に意識が分散されているのが
分かると思いますそしてこんな今の私の
価値観は
今この瞬間にフォーカスする今自分の
身の回りになること
環境であったりそういったことに
フォーカスするという価値観を持ってい
ます
そしてこんな私の性質は
アメーバのようにも思えるんです
イラストにするとこんな風にも見ることが
できます
アメーバは常にその形を変えるんです
変形デザイなんていう風にも言われている
んです
雨は
自分の体の
細胞の一部を
動かして
動かすことで
自由な方向に
身動きを取ることができるんです
アメーバはいろんな要素自分の好きな要素
を
取り入れることで
自分の価値観や
考え方に
磨きをかけていくんです
このイラストで説明いたしますと
真ん中にいるのが私ことアベバそして周り
にあるのが
自分の好きなこと
=アメーバの
栄養分ともいうことができます
このアメーバ
栄養分をきちんと
摂取できている状態ではこんな
穏やかな表情をしていますが
栄養が摂取できなくなるとこんな
不機嫌な顔になってしまいます
でも次にあ私にはこんな自分の好きなこと
や
幸せな環境があったじゃんという風に
俯瞰的に
物事を見れるようになると
先でほどのようにまた落ち着いた表情に
なります
そして
自分の
取り入れたい栄養部これに向かって
ぐにぐにと
体を動かし
キャッチすることで
こんなご機嫌な状態になります
言い換えるならば私
=〇〇
自分の好きなもの=〇〇ではなくて
自分の周りに好きなものがコロッコ点在し
ていてそれを好きなタイミングで
つまみ食いするそんな感覚なんです
[音楽]
でもここではじゃあどうやったら自分が今
幸せなの
ご機嫌なのっていう疑問が湧いてくると
思います
日本の精神科医である
樺沢先生によれば人間の幸せというのは
セロトニン的幸福
オキシトシン的広告
ドーパミン的克服この3つがあり
セロトニン的広告を手に入れる一つの方法
として
自己動作力の
重要性を主張しています
そして
具体的な方法として
気象瞑想マインドフルネッサンポ
プチ幸福アウトプットこの3つを
提唱しています
つまり
未来にフォーカスするのではなくて今の
自分にフォーカスする
そして
自分が今どんな状態であるのか
気づく力が
幸せになるためには不可欠なんです
そして
気づく力を養うことで今自分がある状態を
正確に把握しその都度自分に
合うもの
望んでいるもの好きなものをつまみ食いし
ていくことそれが
幸せにつながると私は思います
私は人と話をするのが好きで
考え方や
価値観を知るのが好きです
例えばエッセイを読むのが好きだったりし
ますまた今こんなステージに立っています
が私は舞台に立つのも好きですそれは
ワクワク
ドキドキそんな自分の心を動かすそんな
感情が湧いてくるからです
ですがこんなちっちゃいことのように思え
てもそのちっちゃな自分の心の動きやその
積み重ねが
あなたの
幸せにしてくれるあなたを高めてくれる
あなたをご機嫌にしてくれるものではない
でしょうか
突然なんですがここで
せっかくなので皆さんに最近あった
プチ幸福を
隣の方と
シェアしていただきたいと思います
例えば私が最近あったプチ幸福は
さっき舞台裏でもう結構緊張してる状態
だったんですけど
他のスピーカーの方やスタッフの方がもう
頑張ってって励ましてくれたのが
すごい
心が
温まったエピソードですこんな感じで
些細なことでいいので今から皆さんに1
秒間お取り出しますのでちょっとあの
知らない方同士でやりづらいところあると
思うんですけどあの積極的にお願いします
いきますよーい
スタート
いいですね皆さん結構
話してくれてますね
[音楽]
はいちょっと異性が以上だよ時間となり
ます
皆さんちょっと会話が弾んでると思うん
ですがここですどう終了とさせていただき
ます
はい皆さんいかがでしたでしょうかこう
やって少しでも自分の好きなことや最近
あったいいことをアウトプットすることで
少し心が
幸せな気持ちになったのではないでしょう
かこんな
感じで1日のちょっとの時間でいいので
自分と向き合う時間を
作ってみましょう
そして一緒に
幸せへの一歩を踏み出していきましょう
本日は
ご清聴いただきありがとうございました
[拍手]